maybe I did he said
just put on some chance to rapper and
Sava and I'll be fine I'm all about
Chicago Boulder Colorado baby boulders
Freddie I can't hear my volume because I
got chance to wrap her bag
I don't we could fill up the next
hundred episodes of daily beady rock
with my weaknesses here here are the
current vulnerabilities because it's
summer extra a little more wine than
normal like summer is when white wine
and Rose a is more interesting to me
actually think one of them interesting
things about how I roll is how little I
focus on the weaknesses bread is a
weakness right now
bread has been a new vulnerability like
I'm weirded out by how much I want bread
at meals came out of nowhere
dear rapture said to me hey let's focus
on weaknesses I just saw you do that
call about last couple weeks of your
health like some of things that you're
worried about like I'll never eat a bag
of potato chips or like I don't need 15
Oreos you know oh there is one thing
tell Lizzy to stop buying those
chocolate-covered pretzels that's
killing me
that's I've eaten a bunch of those in
the last month and they're the best
thing I've ever had you know it's funny
I'm so focused on my strengths I'm so
focused on the opportunities at hand I'm
so focused on the positivity the
optimism of the game that this is
actually going to be the most
challenging episode for me to like to
almost like fester up weaknesses or
think about things to say to bring some
value to this episode super difficult
like you know that's just a much hard
for me to do like I'm just not really
good at respecting my weaknesses I'm not
good at dwelling at my weaknesses I'm
not good at acknowledging my weaknesses
why everybody else is doing that for you
I think to win you need to be your
biggest fan you need to focus on your
strengths I'll appease you on this
episode d rock and give you some
weakness talk but it's not going to be
that good it's not gonna be that easy
and it's surely not going to come up so
easily for me because there's a real
part of me that cuts that cancer out
like we've all got them we've all got
our weaknesses everybody I just think
the people that win
respect their strengths more
Facebook live homies scary you know that
about to head down to Denver and and
give a keynote at Denver startup week
good morning or afternoon thank you so
much for having me
really what I'm going to talk to you
about is attention today and even then I
realized innately
there's a six year old this is not
something you read in a business book at
six I realized that people's eyes and
attention is what I was interested in I
didn't need to pour the lemonade stand
especially if I could get Ravi Turek to
do it I needed to figure out how to get
people to stop think about how sick of a
child I was as a six year old it was
interesting to me to sit at the corner
of a street and watch people drive and
try to figure out which tree or pole was
smarter to put the sign up on because
that's where they were looking and that
is really basically the thing that I
most care about have you found the
people in your life that have already
won and are good that's what I am I'm
good I don't need anything from you guys
I just don't need anything from you guys
I don't want anything I want you to
listen and then go have happiness and
success whether that's work-life balance
whether that's honing your skiing skills
whether that's building a million-dollar
business I don't care I don't need you
to be a hustler I don't need you to be
an entrepreneur I don't need you to be a
businessman I need you to do anything I
need you to pay me back by going out and
doing something with what I'm giving you
paying back the the attention I'm taking
for you paying yourself back you know
giving me the feeling that I'm bringing
value to the world by actually doing
something about what I have to say
that's that's what I'm doing with my
attention what do you do with your
attention the one thing that ties us all
together
everybody in this room the one thing
that ties us all together is before you
tell me how great your agency is or how
great your service is or how great your
startup is or how great your juice is or
how great your new sneaker is before you
tell me and the world how great your
thing is you need my attention
yeah job you brother you got a fun thank
you my man yeah you did a big job of oh
yes I'm about to go on stage and Dee
rocks like item meeting this morning and
then I really early side a work out
right after that before I came here and
I just didn't notice that I put it
inside out and I was about to go on
stage and Dee rocks like your shirts
inside down like it's too late now
I've realized what's going on here one
life I realize that I'm living like this
is our only at-bat and most of you are
it people [ __ ] walking around here
like they're coming back look walking
around here like they're coming back
you're not coming back I appreciate that
I'm a doer I love doing I believe in
doing there's not a lot of animals
running around out there that have built
250 million dollar-plus businesses
there's plenty people bigger than me
better than me winners to me respect
they deserve it but there's not a lot of
people running around with the results
not a lot of and definitely not and this
is the punchline definitely not a lot of
people running around with the results
that I've had that are equally trying to
give as much time as possible to their
audience so that they can taste the
fruits of that as well not a lot of
people with those results that are
obsessed with you having those results -
I just want you to maximize what you got
and I want you to try the thing that
cripples me is the people that aren't
trying out of fear out of laziness out
of being unlucky with parents that
didn't support them being unlucky
growing up in a neighborhood that wanted
to tear them down instead of building
them up so I'm out here feeling guilty
because I had it so good with my mama a
my daddy that I want to give that to you
if I could be that random dude that's
your mentor from afar that you've never
met like so many of you said I just want
to say Gary Vee you know I'm sitting on
the couch and I'm being lazy watching
Facebook and I come across your video it
makes me get up and move makes me go and
do something with it
you're my mentor from afar appreciate
thank you much Mel yeah you can help
that makes me super happy man that's
awesome and that gives you the
opportunity to have something good
happen in your life I'm super [ __ ]
interested like that's legacy baby like
legacy isn't me making six billion or
seven billion legacy is thousands and I
mean hundreds of thousands of people
emailing me and telling me that their
lives are better because their dad or
mom got motivated by something I did and
went on and build something bigger and
better and meaner and leaner and better
for them
I want legacy I now got me into you back
in your day Wine Library TV is that
right yeah you know what drives me you
know what I want to I want to [ __ ]
steal legacy I wanna i want legacy
that's why i want it for you like my
selfishness brings you value just the
way workout is what it is
see you
so nice to meet you yeah your euros just
I like that I appreciate that
no you know what I care about thank you
guys makes me take care
you